[Music]
hi i'm brian levine a product manager on
the Google Docs team this is alan yang
another product manager on the team
nowadays people use a number of tools at
work in order to get things done over
the last few years we've worked to
integrate Google Docs into the G suite
applications as well as third-party
tools but in order to further improve
users workflows we know that we need to
go further to seamlessly integrate
Google Docs into the applications that
users use most
alright I'll do it I'll do it by hand
today we're going to go over existing
integrations that are offered by Doc
sheets and slides as well as introduced
three new types of integrations that are
currently in development we have slides
add-ons templates integrations and
storage integrations we've been working
with a number of partners on these new
integrations and I'm excited to have two
of them with us here today to walk us
through the integrations that are
currently being worked on let's start
with the existing integrations offered
by Google Docs add-ons and Docs and
sheets and AP is for sheets and slides
Docs and sheets add-ons allow
third-party developers to add
functionality that allow users to
accomplish new workflows within the
editors add-ons can be installed from
within Docs and sheets using the
top-level add-on menu and then are
installed from within the editor through
the Chrome Web Store add-ons can
interact with documents and spreadsheets
in a number of manners including showing
sidebars and dialogs within the editor
we've seen add-ons in Google Docs that
have performed a number of use cases
there are add-ons that make it easy to
insert and create diagrams directly in
your document add-ons that have provide
provide writing aids to users to check
grammar and document readability
there are add-ons that offer translation
services as well as workflow as business
tools such as document signatures and
templates lucid chart is an example of a
popular add-on in Google Docs that makes
it easy for users to insert as well as
to create diagrams ranging from mind
maps to flowcharts and other other types
of diagrams all from within the Google
Docs editor sheets add-ons as well as
been created for a variety of use cases
we've seen sheets add-ons that allow for
cross
product integrations add-ons that pull
in data from external sources such as
Google Analytics and third parties there
are add-ons that help with advanced
formatting in order to make spreadsheets
look professional as well as add-ons
that provide workflow assistance such as
automatic document creation and mail
merge let's take a look at yet another
mail merge which is a popular sheets
add-on in this case created by an
independent developer yet another mail
merge makes it easy for users to import
their contact and import their contacts
while in Google sheets and then send
mail merges without even having to leave
the Google sheets editor that was
add-ons for Docs and sheets last year we
also introduced api's for sheets and
slides these api's make it easy for
developers to pull and push data and
content in and out of spreadsheets and
presentations making it easy to
automatically generate spreadsheets and
presentations as well as keep them in
sync with third-party tools where as you
you saw add-on user flows typically
starting from within the editor API user
journeys often start from the
third-party tool we've seen the sheets
API used for integrations across a
variety of use cases including syncing
customer data with your CRM making sure
your timelines stay in sync
within the spreadsheet with your project
management tool and exporting data from
the tools that you use most into sheets
to make it easy to manipulate the data
and create visualizations let's take a
look at a example integration the asana
created using the sheets API from was
within asana
users can view project dashboards in
order to see how projects are going and
keep track of what's going on on their
teams when you're managing a number of
teams this quickly becomes difficult to
do so asana used the sheets api
in order to allow users to open these
reports in Google sheets where they can
create visualizations that make it easy
for them for the team leads and managers
to keep track of what's going on and
identify what areas need their attention
in addition leveraging the sheets API
asana was able to keep the data in
sheets up to date with any changes made
back in asana
similarly the slides api has been used
for a variety of use cases automatically
generating presentations that pull in
customer data from crms adding project
updates to presentations from project
management tools and exporting diagrams
visualizations and other content prosper
works used the slides API in order to
allow users to tag templated fields in
Google slides with metadata that allows
prosper works to pull in Associated
customer data directly from the CRM with
inter dynamically created presentations
no more having to autumn to manually
copy paste all this customer data from
the CRM into each new presentation that
you make prosper works makes it easy to
automatically generate these
presentations for you saving you a lot
of time and energy and creating dynamic
presentations that merge with your
customer data so we've covered add-ons
in Docs and sheets which bring the power
of third-party tools into the editors as
well as api's for sheets and slides
which allow spreadsheets and
presentations to stay in sync with
third-party tools we've gotten great
feedback from both our users our
customers and our partners on these
integrations which is why we're very
excited to announce three new types of
integrations in Google Docs sheets and
slides that are currently in development
we have slides add-ons
templates integrations and storage
integrations
to walk us through these new
integrations we're going to introduce
Louis a sales manager at a retail
company in the Midwest who's going to
help us walk through some examples I'll
now hand it over to Alan to walk us
through a don in slides and template
integrations thanks Bryan and thanks to
all of you for being here today we're
really excited to share what we've been
working on so Louis is wanting to make a
presentation to help pitch a new product
line to her senior leadership in order
for her slides to be successful they're
going to need to be punchy and polished
as you know Google slides is a great
product to help you make presentations
that are beautiful and collaboratively
made with your team today we're very
excited to announce that the same addons
framework that exists for Docs and
sheets today is coming to slides as well
soon users will be able to use sli's
add-ons to leverage partners such as
balsamic lucid chart and Adobe stock in
order to insert beautiful diagrams and
photos into their slides we made slides
add-ons with the intent to help users
become more efficient by eliminating
unnecessary contact switches and we'll
see what that means in a little bit
first let's take a look at what our
partners at Adobe stock have come up
with Louis has drafted her deck but now
she wants to add a bunch of high quality
images in order to help emphasize her
point to do this she thinks there might
be a slides add-on that can help so she
visits the top level add-ons menu and
goes into the add-ons store in the store
she notices that there is a new add-on
from Adobe stock to help her with stock
photos so that's the one she chooses to
install using this add-on Louis now has
access to Adobe stocks entire database
of high-quality stock photos and using
this add-on sidebar she can search
through those photos by a category such
as icons as well as search by theme such
as workplace
for any particular photo she can choose
to buy the license to use a photo she
can preview it in her slide or she can
look at similar images from Adobe stock
when she's settled on the photo she
wants to use she can log into Adobe
stock using either her Adobe stock
credentials or using her Google account
previously in order to accomplish the
same workflow Louis would have had to
open a new tab or window browse through
the partners database there purchased
the licenses to those images there and
then import those photos back into
slides but now with this new slides
add-on Louis is able to accomplish the
same workflow all within the slides
interface this is exactly what we mean
by saying we want to reduce unnecessary
context switches so moving on in a deck
Louis wants to create a rather complex
process flow diagram to help her company
troubleshoot new defective new designs
normally she could do this by creating a
bunch of shapes and slides filling those
shapes with texts connecting them with
lines and arrows and then figuring out
how to lay those out on a slide in an
appealing way but what if she had access
to a more powerful diagramming tool like
lucid chart well we're excited to
announce that our partners at lucid
chart are also working on a slides
add-on with this add-on Louis can log-in
to her lucid chart account and see a
list of all her previous diagrams Louis
remembers that at one point in time she
did create a troubleshooting flow and
indeed she finds it here in her list of
files she's able to preview this diagram
in the lower right corner of the add-on
sidebar and by hitting the blue insert
button she can insert that diagram as an
image into her slide after doing this
though she realizes that she wants to
make a couple of small tweaks this
diagram so she hits the edit button in
the middle of the sidebar and gets taken
to lucid charts powerful new web diagram
editor this allows Louis to use the full
power of the lucid chart tool to edit
the diagram in any way she wishes when
she's done she can return to her slide
and by simply hitting that refresh
button in the
lower right-hand corner the new version
of the diagram will replace the old
version great so Louis now has
successfully completed her diagram slide
but she also wants to create a few
wireframes of what the webpage for this
new product might look like to do this
she can use the balsamic add on balsamic
is a great tool that helps you quickly
create wireframes and prototypes Louis
has installed the balsamic add-on and
she notices that it connects with rugal
drive which is where a balsamic stores
all of her work using the add-on Louis
can browse through her entire list of
all balsamic projects that she's worked
on and with the sidebar she can even
search through those different projects
when she double clicks on a particular
project she can see that individual wire
frames or mocks that make up that
project and she gets a preview of each
of those mocks for any given mock she
can hit the edit button to be taken to
balsamics powerful web editor which
brings the full experience of balsamic
to bear on any diagram she wants to edit
when she's done she can go back to
slides and insert the wireframe or mock
into her slide later on she knows that
if she makes any edits to a particular
mock or wireframe she can always refresh
all the mocks in her deck to get the
latest version these are just some
examples of slides add-ons that our
partners are working on if there are any
developers in the room who would be
interested in working with us to develop
a slides add-on please feel free to drop
us a note at the URL on this slide
because we'll be opening a trusted
tester program in just a couple of
months if you're excited to use slides
add-ons they'll be coming out later this
year and we're excited to have a great
set of launch partners that'll be in the
Chrome Web Store using this new
integration Louis is able to create a
beautiful presentation successfully
pitch her a new product line to
leadership and get it approved she then
goes out to a potential supplier and
negotiates a great deal for her company
but now she needs to encapsulate that
negotiation into a formal document that
both parties will sign to do this
our next ox integration will help
template integrations as you may know
towards the end of last year Google Docs
released the ability for companies to
have their own internal company template
galleries and at this point I'd love to
see a quick show of hands for anybody
who's had a chance to try out these new
galleries in the docs sheets or slides
home screens
great great decent number here terrific
well we hope you've enjoyed that
experience and if you haven't had a
chance to try it yet
we highly highly encourage you to do so
so template integrations are the next
step in templates a template integration
is a pairing of a specific template with
a specific ad on with this pairing we're
excited to bring the power and domain
expertise of our partners to the
flexibility of Google Docs sheets and
slides this features coming out later
this year and is currently under
development but at launch there will be
a set of Google curated template
integrations as well as the ability for
enterprise users to pair their own
templates with any add-ons they have
access to and upload that pairing to
their company gallery let's take a quick
look at how the self's Louis so Louis
suspects that her company has a number
of boilerplate legal contract templates
so she goes to the docs home screen and
looks at her company's internal template
gallery indeed there she finds that her
company has a standardized sales order
form which she can use for this
particular case and she even noticed is
that there is an add-on attached this
template so this is the one she selects
she gets taken to the editor seeing the
template but she also notices that this
template has compared with the DocuSign
add-on turns out Lois's company uses
DocuSign for all of its electronic
signature and needs and one of Lois's
co-workers has helpfully created this
template and paired it with the DocuSign
add-on to be uploaded to the company
gallery and this way Louis knows exactly
the right tool to use through this new
sidebar Louis is able to kick off the
installation flow for the DocuSign
add-on which will then request the
permissions it needs to run after it's
finished installing Louis is able to
launch the DocuSign add-on
from this sidebar this means that lo has
had the right tool ready at her
fingertips for the appropriate moment
this is accomplishing our goal of making
workflows more efficient for enterprise
users
so this DocuSign addon is actually a new
add-on that's currently under
development DocuSign is a recommended 4G
suite partner and already has a number
of integrations with other parts of G
suite there are new Docs add-on is their
latest integration and so today we're
very excited to have marshal Nam product
manager at DocuSign who will walk us
through what this experience looks like
thanks Marshall thank you very much Alan
a quick show of hands I'm curious how
many of you have heard of DocuSign
before ok so I have a good friendly
audience thank you this is good how many
of you have actually signed a document
before so about the same number I'm
gonna say about 85% of you and this is
the real test
how many people here have actually used
DocuSign to send a document to somebody
to get a signature from somebody else so
because that number cut by about 2/3
only about a third of you have done that
and that's good that's good I think I
have something very cool to show you
you'll get to see the other side of that
signature transaction you've been part
of before and you also see how we're
using the power of template integrations
to really unlock additional value make
things a lot easier for people that are
using both G's sweet and DocuSign
together so Louis Louis now that she's
installed the DocuSign add-on using that
very easy and intuitive experience first
gets a summary of the different things
are gonna happen when she goes through a
DocuSign inter DocuSign transaction so
for this sales forum she'll click start
and the first thing she'll do she'll
have that document automatically
imported into DocuSign usually see a
quick preview of it there but if she
needs to add additional things maybe
terms and conditions some supplemental
forms things she has to do for her
company she can reach right back into
Google Drive and pull those additional
documents in right there
and since we're integrated we can
automatically pull her information as
well and we recognize that the way that
the template is structured since its
add-on ready we know that she's going to
be the first sign
the document and for Olivia her customer
that she's signing this deal with all
she has to have is her name in her email
address and she fills that in and it
continues to the next step
you know DocuSign will notify her that
she has something available for your
signature
and for those of you who've signed with
DocuSign which was about 85% of you
you've seen that email before on this
side you can actually customize that
email and send a message maybe saying
hey Olivia its Lois this is the document
the sales order form we agreed on please
sign this for the third of you that said
that you've been through this process
before this is the most time-consuming
part of DocuSign in the sending
experience this is the part where you
take the document you have to actually
mark on the document this is where
you're going to sign this is where you
have to add your name this is where the
date is going to go and through the
power of the template integrations that
we have now available to us at E suite
we've done something very interesting if
you remember back to the original
document it looked like a normal
document completely blank in all those
different fields where you had the sign
and add data but because this is
DocuSign ready because it's integrated
with this template we have automatically
recognized all the different places
where olivia has to put her signature
where she has to fill in her name date
those are automatically recognized and
marked and not only that you can see in
the upper left-hand corner since they're
two signers on this document Lois if she
Scrolls down it's also recognized her
fields as well and recognized which ones
are hers so all of this has been
automatically done for her because of
that strong template integration that we
can do with Google technology at this
point Lois can go and she can add in
additional initial fields on some of
these supplemental forms and make sure
that olivia is going to read these
documents before she goes through that
at that point she's done Olivia Kate
sorry Lois can go in she can sign her
own document first this is a sign and
countersign example she'll click right
here
her signature comes in she can fill in
these additional fields and that's the
magic behind the curtain I think from
this point everybody here that said that
they've signed a document document
before they're used to this experience
and you can see as most of you know
Olivia will come in she'll agree we're
actually doing something very
interesting on the legal side
to protect your business making sure
that people acknowledge the electronic
signature records in signature
disclosure which makes us the legal
equivalent of a written signature and we
make this really intuitive guided
process if you click on that start
button on the left Olivia when she
clicks that she'll be guided right to
the point where she needs to sign that's
automatically recognized those are all
filled out
she'll initial those and she'll finish
the document at this point this is where
a lot of the real magic of making all
this project this process digital comes
in because on Lois aside she's received
an email notification that that has been
completed and that Olivia has come and
signed that document she can go and she
can look at the document directly from
that email cielos information and what's
really interesting on her side what you
may not have known is very important for
this she can actually go and look and
see everything that happened in this
transaction this is not a scribble on a
piece of paper you can see every single
action by every single person that was
taking on this document when it was
viewed when it was sent when it was
signed did somebody look at it and sign
it later and you have a timestamp and
you have an IP address and a geoip if
it's on a mobile device for everything
that happened so you have incredibly
strong legal protection for this is
something that you want for your
business it's also something very
interesting I think it changes things
culturally in sales organizations like
Lois some of our customers tell us
there's a a new term since they get rich
notifications of when different things
happen in the process at the end of the
quarter some of our sales teams they
tell us there's a new phenomenon called
docu stalking where they will actually
go inside of DocuSign and hit refresh
over and over and over again has my deal
closed have they signed no more actually
taking a document printing it putting it
in FedEx envelope and praying that's the
old school well now we move to the cloud
now that we've gone digital we've done
that with G suite it's only becomes
entirely digital and something that
becomes a rich digital transaction for
you and that's what we're really trying
to do we talked about you know the days
or weeks it might take for a FedEx
envelope to get sent out and come back
to you
no more of that if no more days no more
weeks actually 84 percent of our
transactions this were in the cloud we
know are signed in less than a day
actually about half of them are signed
in less than an hour and take all those
costs that go into it costs of lost
business cost of sending signing
printing we actually save about thirty
six dollars per document for our
customers for every single document that
they sign and in no small part thanks to
the reach that we get with G suite and
the Google ecosystem we're bringing a
hundred fifty thousand new customers new
users into our ecosystem every single
day and you know I talked about us
wanting to make every single approval
agreement decision-making process
digital for our customers we want to do
that in all of our everybody's favorite
G suite applications so we have
integrations with Docs which email as
Alan mentioned we'll be having a Doc's
add-on coming in at the end of this
month and we have an Android app as well
I think sometime around a year and a
half ago we started seeing more people
signing on mobile devices and we saw
signing from a desktop or from a
standard web browser so Android has been
a huge part of that in our Android
application we can sign sheets we can
side Docs and all new for this year we
recently refreshed our entire design to
fit with Google material design
standards so very interested to help
people like Luis very interested to help
all of you out there and very excited
about this new template integration in
this partnership with Google Thank You
Ellen
thanks Marshall we're really excited
about the new DocuSign add-on and about
all the other add-ons I can soon be used
in template integrations so if you're a
developer out there who's interested in
creating a template integration with us
we'd love to hear from you please fill
out the form at this URL otherwise
template integrations will be coming out
later this year and we're super excited
about the great set of launch partners
we have for it partners including
DocuSign balsamic lucid chart super
metrics panda doc and EasyBib so with
this new integration Louis was able to
successfully get signatures that she
needed on her sales order form launch
her new product and help her company
grow wobbly so to move on to our next
new Docs integration would love to have
Bryan come back and take the mic thanks
Allen raise your hand if you
occasionally or even regularly use a
storage provider other than Google Drive
okay so I'm seeing a fair number of
hands in the room previously if you
worked at a company that was using a
storage provider other than Google Drive
there was no good way to use Google Docs
to edit your content we're working to
solve this we're working on a new set of
API s that will allow users to create
and edit Google Docs files that are
stored and managed by third party
storage providers last year we announced
our first partner in this effort box
today I'm very excited to announce two
additional partners that we're working
with ignite and Citrix we're working
with ignite and Citrix in order to allow
joint customers to create and edit files
using Google Docs that are stored and
managed in ignite connect and Citrix
ShareFile with these integrations users
will get the both the best of both
Google Docs collaboration and machine
learning functionality alongside the
powerful storage and workflow
functionality offered by ignite connect
and Citrix ShareFile
and now like to invite ronan ven gosh on
stage VP of business development at
ignite to introduce ignite and walk us
through a user journey using Google Docs
with ignite connect thanks Renan thanks
Brian very excited to be here today for
those of you that hope going the wrong
way
here we go for those of you that are not
familiar with ignite we are an
enterprise file sync and share company
among other things we're a Content
intelligence company to be exact
we have two product lines one is ignite
protect which is a data governance
solution and our second product which
we'll be talking about today is ignite
connect you can I connect as an
enterprise file sync and share solution
that's widely deployed around 14,000
business customers around the world use
it across a range of industries and one
of these customers is Design Within
Reach
which is a joint customer of ours and of
Google's and Design Within Reach was was
founded with a vision of getting kind of
heirloom quality design within reach of
the public and they use ignite and
Google Docs both in their headquarters
as well as in there are 34 studios
around the country and one of the cool
things about those studios is that
consultants that work in those studios
do not have their own individual
machines so there's there's a pool of
machines total computers that are
available on the floor and individual
consultants are able to access their
content securely and immediately through
any one of those machines right so let's
walk through kind of a user experience
of a consultant that works in one of
these studios her name is Debbie and she
wants to work on a new proposal for a
customer so to do that she walks up to
any available computer on the studio
floor fires up ignite connect which is
the user interface that you see right
there in front of you and without any
complication at all right from the start
she can fire up a new Google Doc and you
know the document is set up ready to go
with all the features that you'd expect
from from Google Docs all of those
things work right from there but the
cool thing is the document is now stored
and managed behind the scenes by ignite
which means that all the security
policies all the permissions all the
policies that have been created by the
IT management are right there
to help her and she doesn't need to kind
of take any additional steps to share
and manage that content so you know
Debbie edits a document when she feels
it's in good shape enough to share and
get and get some assistance from other
members of the team she can for example
assign a task to her teammate Gary the
task can have a due date Gary gets a
notification he knows that Debbie is
asking him to review the document and
comment all of this is very simple for
Gary because again the permissions are
already set because he already has
access to that folder and ignite and so
he can come in and do his work without
any additional complication other
members of the team again behind the
scenes can go in add their own comments
their own ideas all of this is the
standard functionality of Google Docs
but now is available in a much simpler
way for folks using ignite so once once
everybody is happy with the version that
was created and it's time to share this
with a customer debbie is able to do
that right from within the Google Docs
interface right so by clicking the
sharing functionality over there she
gets a sharing modal that pops up and
then all the advanced features and
sharing capabilities that ignite brings
to the table are available to her she
for example can password protect the
document send a link that expires after
a certain time or in a certain date and
all the other good things that you can
do with ignite Connect once the document
gets to the customer even if the
customer for some reason doesn't have
a Google account they're able to view
the document even without starting a new
account so they can do that right from
within ignite connect without without an
additional account very cool stuff so
but that's just the beginning right
because even though you have all this
functionality of Google Docs and ignite
the real power comes from the company
side from the enterprise side where all
the policies that the organization is
set to enforce the sharing of content
the security of content are handled
behind the scenes by ignite connect the
organization has a an audit trail of
everything that's happened with a
document who opened it who touched it
who edited it when did they do that what
devices they did that from and of course
that's something that comes in very
handy in cases of an audit or a legal
challenge or anything like that and you
know the user experience while all these
security features are happening behind
the scenes all this power is there from
the users perspective things are
actually much simpler than they were
before right so that we can start this
document right from within ignite
connect she doesn't need to context
switch she can also do that from the
ignite desktop application that she's
got on our machine so really the best of
both worlds the users happy the
administrators happy and and things are
going the right way so you know to sum
it up I think the power of this this
type of integration is really in the
fact as Bethany camp of Design Within
Reach says the ability to let you know
employees focus on their customers
rather than on managing the content
doing all the hard work and the heavy
lifting behind the scenes and the rest
just happens by itself so we're very
very excited about this new integration
with Google Docs and we're looking
forward to making that available to our
customer base thank you
thank you running great so in this
session we've covered a lot we walked
through the existing types of
integrations which include add-ons in
Docs and sheets and api's for sheets and
slides and then we introduced three new
types of integrations that are currently
in development slides add-ons template
integrations and storage integrations we
saw integrations from large partners as
well as from independent developers and
we walked through use cases that spanned
design legal and marketing I want to
thank all our partners for working with
us to integrate Google Docs more
seamlessly into users workflows and a
special thanks to Ronan and Marshall for
walking us through some examples for
those who would like to learn more about
Google Docs and integrations here are a
few sessions that are related to this
talk at the top machine learning and
explore in Google Docs these are all
occurring tomorrow sessions on G suite
integrations and leveraging Apps Script
api's and add-ons as well as leveraging
Google Docs and G suite in order to
empower your legal and sales teams
[Music]
you